and my mother's father was a wealthy man
but gave nothing jackie gleason right
your mother's father was jackie gleason
right but you guys were poor
absolutely so jackie was jackie gleason
at the time
tipping dorman hundred dollar bills but
you know meanwhile
you know uh hot dogs for thanksgiving
for his daughter and
and her husband yeah and kids well was
there a reason behind that
i don't know what the reason was to
honest to be honest to god i met gleason
twice in my life
so um i think there was probably an
actor idea
uh that he didn't approve of which is
strange because he was and he came from
great poverty
but my dad wrote that championship
season and then became a very big
success
had never been in a movie and got hired
in the exorcist which is
a story for another day it's a great
story how he got that
so you know he went from cashing three
dollar checks at the bank
to in a year and a half when he appealed
surprise being nominated for an oscar in
the biggest movie of all time
and he's a kid ultimately aside from his
talent from
scranton pennsylvania coal mine and
he couldn't handle it so that was
as great as it was lifting us out of
poverty and all this wondrous stuff that
was the end of dad because he was gone
after that
well what about i gotta i'm thinking
about jackie now there's all this
success did jackie come back into the
picture
absolutely he did oh yeah and absolutely
because they wanted to make movie
versions
of uh that championship season so
gleason then wanted to play the coach
and i think that's the point that my dad
said go yourself
uh which he had every right to do um
look
it there's a lot of crazy you know
shakespearian
fear and vengeance and anger in our
business and
i can't explain why as a father i can't
explain why you wouldn't help your child
i i don't know but that was the case
look from my dad's standpoint
it made him you know delivering welfare
checks and driving cabs and being a
waiter
it made him say
i have to be a success and i think i
told kiefer this when we were doing the
play
that he came home one day we lived in
flesh and queens and i was pushing my
brother on a broken down playground
in this building we lived in he said he
came up the uh
the subway stairs he looked at us and i
was pushing my brother and he said he
started to cry he said i'm getting them
out of here
and he went up in the elevator and he
started writing that championship
season that day wow and so you know
you d you you go with what you go with
and what was your relationship with him
was it pretty
i mean it was definitely oh no
definitely fraught because he was
because he was gone um had you know
major
we've talked about you know your dad i
don't know but
mine had major alcohol issues and drugs
and the truth is when he had this
amazing sort of comet ball of fame and
couldn't
take it we lived back east and he moved
to california
you know bought a porsche sort of lived
his james dean fantasies out and
sort of sadly pissed away
this amazing amazing career that he had
because at the time championship season
was the longest running
broadway show since streetcar named
desire
and he was gives one of the penultimate
performances
in the exorcist to 70s performance movie
doesn't work without him
so he can write his own parts in his own
ticket
and he just got caught up in the typical
uh hollywood sort of downturn the spiral
so from that you know as a young man you
look up to your father and you also need
him to be there
but in some edible sort of way when i
decided to do what i wanted to do
i just cut that line man and wanted to
become my own person
and uh so i never talked about him or my
grandfather or any of those things in
the early days
ever how was the relationship towards
the end before he um passed
did you kind of salvage things a little
bit there was times
where we were strange for a while but
towards the end yes i mean for
because you just have to look at for
them as you said this is who they are
you know you're going to change them
it's crazier for us to think that we're
going to change our parents
this is all he could do i mean in 1938
you're born in there and
you you if you want to have sex you
marry someone right then you have kids
you're not ready to do anything and then
you all of a sudden follow
your passions or your mistakes or your
demons and so you have to see you know
who they are
look doing the play all those years
later not only
reignited my uh uh relationship with
kiefer which
you know i love like a brother but it
also
in the court battle later on because i
did that play
and i did it in new york that's why i
got uh gus back
so in some karmic way for everything he
did
if i didn't do that play at that moment
you know and have my son visit me at at
that moment
that piece of evidence that i used i
never would have won and when
kiefer did that championship season in
yeah yeah did you you said something
about didn't you take
some of his ashes i had his urn because
of ashes and i just put it on the stage
as part of the as part of the things i
figured i knew he would love this cast
and figure might as well put him up
there